d'après vous qui est-ce qui vous connaît
le mieux les garçons vont me répondre
maman évidemment à moins que ce ne soit
votre chéri depuis le temps que vous
vivez ensemble ils ou elles vous connaît
parfaitement
oui de manière générale ce sont nos
proches qui nous connaissent le mieux
pourtant une étude récente a montré
qu'il suffit de connaître 250 like sur
facebook 250 ait c'est quand même pas
beaucoup pour qu'un algorithme soit plus
fiable que vos proches dans l'évaluation
de votre personnalité
en clair non seulement facebook connaît
votre sexe votre cuivre aux orientations
sexuelles et politique
mais facebook connaît également
relativement bien votre profil
psychologique
c'est quelque chose qui va relativement
loin malheureusement on va aller encore
plus loin
qu'en est il de vos moteurs de recherche
tous les jours vous interrogez les
fameux google yahoo et bing enfin tous
ces grands moteurs commerciaux qui font
notre quotidien
quand vous êtes sur facebook vous savez
que vous êtes dans un espace public
aussi on a tendance quand même à
s'autocensurer mais quand on interroge
son moteur de recherche fondamentalement
on se pense anonyme donc les requêtes
que l'on formule sur google ou autre
sont potentiellement très intime voilà
un exemple qui vient d'une fuite célèbre
qui date de quelques années
impossible de dormir avec un mari qui
ronfle combien de romance en ligne
conduite au sexe comment aller à l'omni
hôtel de san antonio en venant de
houston et comment rendre un homme fou
de désir pour vous tout ceci est quand
même extrêmement explicite savoir que
les grands moteurs de recherche dispose
de ce type d'informations sur nous fait
froid dans le dos mais il ya plus grave
encore il ya plus grave parce que ce
sont les fondements mêmes de la
démocratie qui sont en jeu on sait
depuis les révélations snowden que les
services de sécurité américains ont mis
en place un vaste système de
surveillance de minces à l'échelle de la
planète
à l'échelle de la planète keith
alexander qui dirigeait la aînés c'est à
l'époque a même déclaré
moi mon objectif c'est d'écouter tout
l'internet mans
la pensée de son mouvement illimité aux
etats unis c'est se tromper
je vous rappelle les débats dans le
cadre de la france l'an passé où il ya
deux ans à propos de la loi
renseignements et je vous rappelle tout
les loin qui ont été adaptés adopté à
travers l'europe au cours des dernières
années
on est là dans un changement qualitatif
fondamentale il est important que vous
compreniez que pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
les états ont la possibilité de
surveiller l'ensemble de leur population
et par simple inclination naturelle non
pas par volonté dictatorial ou par
volonté de contrôle absolu par simple
inclination naturelle c'est ce qu'il
s'efforce de fait on peut reprendre ses
engrais nick qui est une juriste de
l'université de standford le secret le
mensonge la capacité de pression que
confère l'espionnage de masse est
incompatible avec une gouvernance
démocratique du par et pour le peuple
et c'est pourtant là que nous ce que
nous vivons actuellement
alors maintenant vous pourrez toujours
me dire que vous n'avez rien à cacher
vous et moi n'avons effectivement rien à
cacher et pourtant on met des rideaux à
nos fenêtres
pourquoi est ce qu'on met des rideaux à
nos fenêtres non pas parce qu'on veut
cacher des activités illégales ou
moralement condamnable tout simplement
parce que l'homme a besoin de moments
d'intimité il y a des moments où on a
besoin de se retrouver seul pour se
livrer à telle ou telle activité
ça fait partie des besoins fondamentaux
de l'humanité alors sans aller jusqu'à
la célèbre formule si vous n'avez rien à
cacher vous n'avez rien à craindre
là quand même des situations qui
interroge prenons qu'un de feed bits
donc vous connaissez tous ces bracelets
connectés qui nous servent à suivre
notre activité physique
parmi les activités physiques que fitbit
peut suivre se trouve naturellement les
activités sexuelles puisque celles ci
sont consommatrices de calories en plus
ou moins mais elles le sont alors que
l'on donne à une entreprise privée le
détail de ce
vie sexuelle ma foi ça relève de la
décision personnelle
mais quand suite à une erreur de
manipulation je parle bien là d'une
erreur de manipulation et non pas d'un
piratage ou de je ne sais quoi
le détail de ces activités sexuelles se
retrouvent librement accessibles sur
internet comme vous pouvez le voir à
travers une simple recherche google
alors là la problématique change de
dimension pensez simplement à votre
patron qui constate ainsi qui vous
arrive de manquer singulièrement de
concentration pendant vos heures de
travail
pensez également à toutes ces structures
tous ces organismes de crédit
d'assurance qui n'ont de cesse qui
n'auront de cesse que d'utiliser nos
traces sur internet pour sélectionner
les clients les moins risqués et donc
les clients les plus profitables je vous
parle là de nos beaux pays démocratique
où fondamentalement même si je considère
qu'il ya effectivement un certain risque
pour la démocratie fondamentalement nous
restons des gens libres mais les choses
sont infiniment plus graves dans les
pays dictatoriaux
la chine met actuellement en place
qu'ils appellent le système de crédit
social le système de crédit social c'est
un système qui vous attribue qui vous
retire des points en fonction de votre
activité en fonction de votre
comportement et c'est un système qui est
très largement basé sur les activités
sur internet
si vous vous comportez conformément au
souhait du parti puisque
fondamentalement c'est bien de ça dont
il s'agit vous gagnez des points vous
aurez des avantages dans les magasins
dans les transports vous aurez même une
certaine priorité dans les hôpitaux
inversement si vous vous comporter de
manière déviante vous allez perdre des
points
vous allez être puni un journaliste
critique du us se retrouve actuellement
dans l'incapacité d'exercer sa
profession parce que il a perdu la
totalité de ses accès à ces réseaux
sociaux et il a d'énormes difficultés à
se déplacer les choses peut aller plus
loin encore puisqu'il s'agit là d'une
question de vie ou de mort
d'innombrables activistes sur internet
sont actuellement ont été emprisonnés où
sont encore emprisonnés voir certains
comme dans
cette carte habiles ont été exécutés ces
algues vertes habile a été exécuté en
2015 par le régime syrien
comment lutter contre ces abus
comment lutter contre la pression
normatif qu'impose la surveillance de
masse comment lutter contre ce phénomène
bien connu qui fait que quand on est
surveillé quand on se sait surveillé
on va avoir tendance même inconsciemment
à modifier son comportement de manière à
agir conformément à ce que l'on pense
des surveillants comment préserver la
liberté d'expression sur internet est la
liberté d'information comment retrouver
un internet libre
non la réponse va vous surprendre parce
que le dark net est surtout connu comme
un espace interlope où se déroulent des
choses absolument innommable c'est vrai
mais darknet c'est bien plus que ça
darknet c'est d'abord et avant tout un
outil au service des libertés qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un darknet qui édita
darknet mais enfin qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un d'arquenay fondamentalement on va
appeler d'arc naître tous et sous
espaces d'internet on peut communiquer
de manière anonyme
ça fonctionne de manière relativement
simple sur le principe c'est à dire que
au lieu de vous relier directement aux
services que vous souhaitez consulter
votre connexion va passer par un
ensemble d'intermédiaires qui vont en
cash et là qui vont en cacher l'origine
vous connaissez probablement le plus
célèbre des darnes est à savoir le
réseau tor qui n'a pas été développée
par la mire failli par la mafia russe en
mai par l'armée américaine au début des
années 2000 thor est très simple d'usagé
vous suffit de charger un navigateur le
tord brothers pour à la fois aller sur
un web caché fameux dark web ou pour
surfer anonymement sur le web ouvert le
dark web
si célèbres dont vous habitants entendu
parler là où se trouvent les fameux
marché noir de la drogue etc
représentent moins de 3% du trafic de
tort plus de 97% de la bande passante de
thor est utilisé pour aller sur le web
ouvert donc pour contourner la censure
donc pour échapper à la surveillance les
principaux promoteurs du darknet ce ne
sont pas les grandes mafias une fois
encore ce sont les grandes organisations
de journalistes à commencer par
reporters sans frontières
reporters sans frontières met à
disposition ce qu'ils appellent le kit
de survie numérique
un kit de survie numérique ce n'est rien
d'autre qu'un ensemble
d'outils destinés à accéder aux darknet
vous êtes un journaliste de guerre vous
êtes un journaliste d'investigation
vous avez besoin de protéger vos sources
vous avez besoin de vous protéger vous
même le dard net et % un outil
absolument irremplaçables vous êtes un
lanceur d' alerte
je pense à wikileaks mais je pense bien
sûr à toutes ces alertes qui ont eu lieu
au cours des dernières années
à l'abri du darknet un nombre un très
grand nombre de scandales sont venus au
jour en particulier dans le domaine de
la de l'évasion fiscale
le dark net est un outil de lutte contre
les abus des puissants
ensuite penser que l'espionnage de masse
se limite à la surveillance des
populations c'est se tromper les
services de renseignement ont aussi pour
mission l'espionnage économique vous
avez à l'écran un fac similé de l'ordre
donné à la haine et c'est d'espionner la
france
alors si vous êtes une grande structure
vous avez les moyens de vous offrir des
systèmes sécurisés
mais si vous êtes une pme si vous êtes
une star tu une start-up technologiques
juin de grenoble un endroit il ya
énormément de start-up technologiques
n'ai pas les moyens de vous offrir ces
outils avec le darknet vous pouvez
disposer à moindre coût on parle là de
logiciels open source dont qui
généralement sont gratuits doughty qui
vous permette à la fois de communiquer
de manière anonyme et de communiquer une
manière confidentielle
le dark net est un outil au service de
la protection des entreprises
enfin le dark knight est naturellement
un outil au service des dissidents
lampard dissidents j'entends aussi bien
la dissidence sociétal que la dissidence
politique qu'est ce que je veux dire par
dissidents sociétal mais pas sans savoir
que l'homosexualité est condamnée dans
un grand nombre de pays notamment en
afrique
les communautés homosexuelles africaine
utilise le darknet pour exister en tant
que communauté pour s'organiser pour
communiquer et ceci à l'abri de la
surveillance est le darknet est
naturellement un outil au service des
dissidents politiques puisque c'est un
outil qui leur permet de se de se cacher
de la surveillance
quand il travaillait sur la société de
contrôle en cours d'émergence cette
société qui va se substituer à la
société disciplinaires dans laquelle
nous vivons encore deleuze à la suite de
foucauld de bureau et d'autres a
notamment déclaré face aux formes
prochaine de contrôles incessants en
milieu ouvert
il se peut que le plus dur enfermement
nous paraissent appartenir à un passé
délicieux et bienveillant l'important ce
sera peut-être de créer des vacuoles de
non-communication les interrupteurs pour
échapper aux contrôles
le dark knight c'est précisément l'une
de ces vacuoles l'un de ces
interrupteurs à leurs fins à cette
société de contrôle quand qu'engendre la
généralisation d'internet
face à cette maison de verre au sein de
laquelle on cherche à nous forcer à
vivre darknet est un outil fondamental
de préservation de nos libertés
d'aujourd'hui mais plus encore de nos
libertés de demain en ce sens c'est pas
darknet qu'il devrait s'appeler mais
bien freenet je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]